asthma is not her real name but her pain
is a survivor of rape she is
inconsolable I cried for help after two
of the attackers threatened and later
gagged me with a piece of cloth they
forced me into a
room she says they raped her repeatedly
because she refused to disc shows the
whereabouts of her husband an
activist this wasn't the first time
asmos assaulted in 2022 before her
wedding she tells us she was also raped
she says she couldn't tell anyone then
not even her family for fear of
rejection I went to the hospital but
couldn't bring myself to tell the nurses
I was
raped healthcare workers say there are
hundreds of unreported cases of sexual
violence among the women and children
arriving in E Chad after escaping the
violence in Sudan doctors say most cases
of rape are not reported because of fear
of stigma pregnancies resulting from
such attacks are rarely terminated
because of cultural and religious
beliefs the victims are often left to
deal with the trauma and stigma
alone social worker Hab ABD Rahman
admits a major crisis is unfolding as
many survivors of sexual violence have
been rejected by their
families if we could get help the
victim's recovery process could begin
but at the moment there's nothing to
work with when you go to the hospitals
there aren't even enough beds for
emergency
cases hospitals and Aid agencies are
focused on providing food to more than
400,000 refugees and treating the
critically ill rape cases aren't a
priority right now which means survivors
of sexual violence like asthma must find
ways to Bear their grief and pain in
silence ahamed rris Al jazer adre on the
CH Sudan
border now the situation on the ground
is such that there are no medical
facilities no Consultants no social
workers to deal with to help these
victims to deal with the problems now
these problems are continuing to mount
you talking about more than a million
refugees from West dafo alone who've uh
thousands of them have gone through this
process some have some of them have been
attacked repeatedly uh 600,000 from
earlier conflicts in De like for for
example this lady we've spoken to who is
still married uh she's been attacked
even last year and there are several of
such cases here doctors are confused as
to what to do with these ones when we go
to the hospitals they say when they go
to the hospitals for consultation and
for help they really
cannot be helped simply because there
isn't enough facility and doctors are
more worried with more critical issues
like saving lives like people bleeding
to death or children hanging in for dear
life s yeah Ahmed Idris reporting from
audre in Chad thank you so much for that
reporting